[Music]
just before our love God lost you
say I am as constant as the Northern
Star and
I constantly in the dark
where's that at if you want me I'll be
in the
[Music]
board on the back of a cartoon
coaster in the blue TV screen
light I drew a map of
Canada Oh
[Music]
Canada your face getch on it
twice and you're in my like C
Wine you taste so bitter and so sweet oh
I could drink a case of
you darling and that
would still be on my
feet I'd still be on my feet
[Music]
oh I am a lonely
painter I live in a box of
[Music]
pains I'm I'm frightened by the devil
but I am dra to those ones that ain't
afraid do you remember you told me love
was touching
Souls surely you've touched my
car part of you pours out of
me and these Li from time to
time
and you are in my like holy
wine you're taste so bitter so sweet oh
I could drink a case of
you darling and I
would still be on my
feet I'd still be on my
feet
[Music]
I met a woman she had a mouth like yours
she knew your life she knew your devils
and your deeds and she said go to him
and be with them if you
can but be prepared to
bleed and you are in my blood you are my
holy
wine you taste so bitter so sweet oh I
could drink a case of
you darling
W still be on my
feet I'd still be on my
[Music]
feet St me on my
feet
i' still be on my
[Music]
feet